[Joe] From portion sizes to exclusives,
we wanted to find out all
the differences between KFC
in the US, UK, Japan, and India.
This is "Food Wars."
So, at the KFC in Japan, you
can order your chicken pieces
in, one piece, two pieces,
three pieces, four pieces
Five piece bucket that
comes with only leg pieces.
In the UK you can get
buckets in three sizes,
you can get a six-piece.
Eight pieces.
And the largest one of them
all a 10-piece leg bucket.
12 pieces.
Or you can get a 14 piece.
Or 16 piece bucket.
Woo, that's a lot of chicken.
In Japan, we have three drink sizes.
So we have a small.
In the US our drinks come in medium.
And this is what a large drink looks like.
Here in India, we don't serve
cups, we just serve cans.
If you want, you can also
get half a gallon bag
of your favorite drink of choice.
Look at this thing.
It's convenient.
So the fries are the KFC in
Japan come in three sizes.
So this is small.
These are regular fries.
And back again the large.
Then we've got a box.
Let us now measure the large
to see how much we get.
You can do it.
Now, of course the US
has a chicken sandwich.
You can also get it spicy or classic.
This is classic.
I got this little guy, a Chicken Little,
look at this guy, huh?
There's the little guy.
Comes of pickles, mayo.
So instead of a chicken
sandwich, what we call ours
is the Chicken Fillet Burger.
I think it's pretty much the same thing.
It's like breaded and fried chicken
between two buns with some
lettuce and some mayonnaise.
We also have something
called the Zinger Burger
which is pretty much the same thing,
but the spice level is
amped up a little bit.
You can also turn these
burgers into a Tower Burger.
What that does is adds
cheese and a hash brown
to the burger, which in my opinion,
very worthwhile addition.
Now we have special sandwiches.
This one right here is
called Japanese-Style
Chicken Katsu Sandwich.
So let's take a look inside.
So it's got mayo and it's got cabbage
and chicken katsu right there.
(speaks in Japanese)
Hmm, oh, this sauce is
like soy sauce-based sauce
and it's a little bit sweet,
and this mayo is also
great with this sauce.
This looks really small, but
it has huge amount of chicken.
So if you eat this,
you're going to be full.
And next one, we've got Chicken Fillet.
Wow, this is also huge.
Alright, so this one right here
is called Black Hot Sandwich.
oh, look at this.
It's like pepper mayo.
I just tasted this pepper mayo
but it has a little like spiciness.
Oh, man, it's too strong.
I wouldn't get it, be careful.
All right, let's move on
to chicken sandwiches.
Here in India, we don't have
an American Chicken Sandwich
but we have a Zinger
and a smaller sandwich
called a Krisper, cute.
The Krisper looks like it wants to grow up
and be a Zinger someday.
They also come in two
variants: Spicy Krisper
and a Tandoori Zinger.
Let's taste all of them.
Oh, that's pretty yummy.
They've used a different
kind of mayonnaise here.
It has a bit of sweetness to
it and a spicy kick at the end.
And now for the legendary
Zinger, back in the day
there were only two fast
food chains here in India.
It was McDonald's and KFC.
And while McDonald's had more
affordable burger options
the KFC Zinger was so delicious,
it was always a treat to eat.
Mmh, and it still is.
I love that they use
a whole boneless piece
of proper chicken in there.
Delicious mayo, it's so delicious.
Okay, now let's try the spicy variants.
This is the Spicy Krisper.
Look at this sauce.
It's almost blood-red.
I'm excited.
Oh my God, the sauce almost
has a szechuan taste to it.
Next up, the Zinger, but tandoori.
Hmm, I love the fullness of the chicken
that comes in these burgers versus
like a mince chicken patty
in other restaurants.
And so much bite to it, so juicy tender.
That all sounds amazing.
Stop, you're going too fast.
I have to say, those
sandwiches look delicious
and I am jealous.
All right, moving away from chicken,
India's KFC actually has
vegetarian alternatives
for all our burgers.
That is a Vegetarian Krisper,
a Vegetarian Spicy Krisper
and a Vegetarian Zinger.
Now while India has a majority
population of non-vegetarians
around 70 percent, there is
a huge vegetarian population,
which is why a lot of
fast food restaurants
have to make sure they have
a lot of vegetarian options
on their menu to make it more approachable
and acceptable for all people over here.
There's also levels to
vegetarianism over here
that are, "I will eat egg
but not chicken" vegetarians.
There are, "I will eat fish
but not lamb" vegetarians.
There are, "I will eat the curry
but not the pieces" vegetarians.
There are, "I am vegetarian
only on Tuesdays" vegetarians.
There are, "I have made a promise to God
for this one month" vegetarians.
There are, "I am vegetarians,
so you will all be
vegetarian" vegetarians.
They're the weird ones and we
try not to talk about them,
which is why KFC in India
brands itself as just KFC.
There's no Kentucky Fried
Chicken anywhere here
because obviously I'm not
going to go to a place
that's named that if I'm one of these
many types of vegetarians.
KFC in America has extra-crispy chicken.
This is the best type of chicken.
I mean, look at this.
I don't know what they do to this
but the skin is practically falling off.
It is so crispy and so delicious.
I love extra crispy so much.
So we also have Dip Pack, oh.
So it's got Colonel
Crispy and some nuggets
and boneless Kentucky and
some original chicken.
So this Dip Pack, it
comes with these fries.
So if you want to have a little bigger one
you can order Dip Barrel.
I mean it's double amount of this Dip Pack
so it's going to be very big.
So this one right here,
is called Four-piece Red Hot Chicken Box
and it comes with a pie and fry
and a medium drink.
And actually we have other box options,
like Four-piece Half Hot
and Half Original Box,
And it comes with fries as well
and Six-piece Half Hot
and Half Original Box,
it comes with fries again.
So in Japan we have (speaks Japanese).
That means Chicken Day, it's
on every 28th of the month.
And two stands for "ni"
and eight stands for "wa"
and it becomes "niwa."
And niwa is synonymous with niwatori.
Niwatori means "chicken."
So that's what it's called, "Chicken Day."
Okay, let's start with chicken in India.
Apart from the crispy chicken,
we also get Smoky Red Chicken.
Oof, wow.
I believe this is KFC's
answer to tandoori chicken.
If you guys don't know what a tandoori is,
it's basically a cylindrical oven
that they light up using
word fire or charcoal.
And it adds a really smoky flavor
to the meats or breads
that you cook inside of it.
I doubt KFC's across the
country have an actual tandoor
but the flavoring
definitely smells of that.
The marinade looks like that.
Oh my God!
That's actually pretty good.
You know what, KFC?
Pretty good job.
You have to remember, KFC is competing
with a lot of Mughlai restaurants
across every Indian city.
And while this doesn't have
as much of that smoky char
that a lot of tandoori kebabs
have, it has a lot of flavor,
and the chicken is quite juicy.
Good job.
It's super spicy though,
so if you're somebody
who can't handle spice, go
a little easier on this one.
When an Indian says
something's spicy, it's spicy.
The pot pie that they have here,
they're not kidding when
they say pie and the pot pie.
How thick this is.
I gotta say the pot pie
actually looks quite good.
We love meat pies here in the UK,
you'll often see people
tucking into like a steak
and kidney pie or a chicken pie,
but yeah, they should probably put that
on the menu over here.
I think they'd cash in
on the British market.
Speaking of big dishes of
stuff, the Famous Bowl.
Once upon a time, a KFC employee was like,
"I could have put everything into one dish
and call it a day."
And ta-da, the Famous Bowl was born.
This has to be like three pounds
Now, Joe, I'm glad you also think
that the Famous Bowl doesn't do that great
because, to me, that
looks like a nightmare.
We currently have a Nashville
Hot Chicken and Hot Tenders.
I went ahead with the tenders.
I've just been informed
this was a big TikTok thing
for a minute, something about
biting it and crunching it.
I don't know anything about that,
I can say just by holding this
there's no way these are crispy.
Well, it's not that spicy, it's not spicy.
I do like this a lot.
I'm going to stop eating up.
Oh, that heat's catching up with me.
Slow burn, slow build on the heat.
All right, so here we've
got two Special Twisters.
So this one right here is called
Pepper Mayonnaise Twister.
Oh, it looks great.
Nine out of 10.
KFC, thank you.
Thank you for making me happy.
So next we got, oh, Teriyaki
Twister, should be great.
It's kinda gross.
It's got mayo and Colonel
Crispy, some veggies,
and I hope this is teriyaki sauce.
(speaks in Japanese)
Mmh, mmh, mmh.
It looks gross, but it tastes incredible.
10 out of 10, congratulations.
Oishi, it means delicious.
Look how tiny those twisters are.
I can eat like three of
those easily, easily.
I said this one right here,
it's called Colonel Crispy,
is it only in Japan?
I cannot confirm the difference
between a Colonel Crispy
and a KFC chicken tender.
They call their tenders Colonel Crispies.
And we call our Colonel
Crispies, chicken tenders.
There's a few other, the
language differences,
like instead of chicken tenders,
we call ours chicken mini-fillets.
It's been a while since I ordered this one
but it still has crispy bits.
Good job.
Japanese KFC's technology,
state of the art.
One iconic dish that you'll find
on the KFC India menu is biryani.
And so KFC India has
taken a very bold decision
to launch their own biryanis.
They come in four flavors.
Number one: Classic
Chicken, nice and crispy.
Number two: Popcorn Chicken.
number three: the Spicy Red
Chicken that I really enjoy.
And number four: the Veg Patty,
which it's so tempting to
just push that to the side
because veg biryani is
already just a concept
but really not a fan of over here.
But just for now, you can stay here.
Okay, I'm going to begin with
the Popcorn Chicken Biryani,
which is just so
blasphemous to begin with.
It's not a biryani, it's,
I'm so upset right now.
This one, the Spicy Red Chicken,
has a bit of that tandoori wipe to it.
They really tried to
overcompensate with the spices,
there's a lot of clove flavor.
Just to convince you,
you are eating a biryani,
so go easy on that curry.
I could eat this, like if I was hungry,
not a biryani though.
Also the US KFC that you
can't get in Japan are wings.
You can get wings at the
KFC in units of six, 12,
24 or 48.
I believe the three wing flavors
that I got here are standard
Buffalo, the Honey Barbecue,
and if you're at total wuss, unsauced?
What's wrong with you?
Yeah, very sketchy.
You can also get them in a
limited time Nashville Hot Sauce.
All right, so we have nuggets.
We have three pieces, five pieces,
and they come with only ketchup.
Our biscuit on the other hand
is just this Southern
style, not exactly a scone
but kind of looks like
one from a distance.
Dry cornmeal biscuit.
Oh yeah.
Here we've got KFC biscuit.
It comes with Honey Maple KFC.
Ah.
This is good, but maple, it's
a little bit sweet for me.
Mac and cheese,
I can't believe you guys do
not have macaroni and cheese.
Love mac and cheese.
Mashed potatoes and gravy.
You don't have that in Japan?
Guys, guys, demand this
from your Japanese KFC,
you want the mashed potatoes and gravy.
Now we have a slightly different approach
to sides in the UK compared to the US.
For example, our corn comes on the cob.
Baked beans, these are slightly different
to the regular beans that you
might put on toast in the UK.
They have kind of a barbecue
sauce flavor to them.
And now for the quickest sauce talk ever.
[Announcer] "Sauce talk."
KFC Sauce.
The KFC Sauce is like
a brown mustard mayo.
Yeah, the sauce is good.
There are a few sources which
are exclusive to the UK.
For example, we have this
Spicy Supercharger Dip,
which is kind of like a
spicy mayo type thing.
We have some sweet chili
sauce, garlic mayonnaise,
another really good option.
Garlic mayo on chips.
It's just fantastic.
These three dipping sauces.
So, we've got barbecue sauce and mustard.
And this pink one is called Mentaiko Mayo.
mentaiko means is like spicy cod roe
and a very popular taste in Japan.
This is actually great.
I'll dip this.
Mmh.
It tastes fantastic.
Winner.
India does not have too
many exclusive dips.
In fact, we just have a
veg eggless mayonnaise
and a tandoori masala mayonnaise.
It's time to taste.
I'm using the same hand
because here in India
we don't eat with our left hand.
If you're wondering why,
commenters, you let them know.
Why don't Indians eat
with their left hand?
Well, it's just mayonnaise,
so good job on that.
Mayonnaise again with a
little bit of a sweet,
but also spicy kick to it.
I wish we had more options,
especially considering
there are so many different
delicious chicken options.
I love to be able to dip
my tenders in more sauces.
That is a weird sentence.
Desserts at a US KFC.
You can get this chocolate chip cookie.
Recognize that guy?
(chuckles) I just look just like this guy.
And finally, a chocolate chip cake.
Here in India, we have
two exclusive desserts
a choco mud pie and a coffee mousse cake.
Oh boy!
Just look at this cross
section, my friend.
Next up, coffee mousse cake.
Yeah, these are pretty
average as desserts.
Fountain drinks.
There's a few that we can get
that you guys cannot over there in Japan.
The first one is a beverage
that I have yet to make one
human being who enjoys it.
Of course, I'm talking about Sierra Mist
maybe grossest soda ever.
It's so bad.
Another drink that you can get at KFC
that you can't get at Japan.
And here it is right here.
Mountains Dew is great.
When I was in college, I
worked at a pizza place.
I drank so much Mountain Dew I threw up
and now I'm drinking Mountain Dew,
let's see if I can do it again.
My favorite beverage,
Mountain Dew Sweet Lightning.
So good, so good.
So here we've got
Japanese exclusive drinks.
This one right here is water,
but it comes with this Assam tea pack.
It's supposed to be hot, but it's cold.
And next one, we've got coffee.
And this one right here
is roasted rich coffee.
(speaks in Japanese)
It's a little bit bitter
than that normal coffee.
And here we got all Earl Grey iced tea.
It's not sweet at all.
And next one, it melon soda.
It has bright green color.
Horrible.
It's too sweet.
Here is ginger ale, nothing special.
And the last one, it's not
Natchan Refreshing Orange.
Exclusive drinks in KFC,
India, we have Mirinda,
which is an orange soda and Red Bull.
Let's talk about Mirinda.
This is a drink that
really evokes nostalgia.
Nineties kids really know
what I'm talking about
when I say:
Mirinda.
The drinks are just
normal, nothing special
but chickens are finger-licking good.
Now, usually we'd have even
more exclusive menu items
to show you, but unfortunately UK KFCs
are currently operating
with a reduced menu.
Here's what you could normally
find on the menu at a UK KFC.
A vegan burger, the Big Daddy Burger,
a range of chicken wraps
some rice boxes, onion
rings, curry sauce, Krushems
and a full range of hot drinks
including English Breakfast tea.
So let's talk about Christmas in Japan.
So Christmas is one of the
biggest events in Japan
even though about one percent
of Japanese people are Christians,
we just enter Christmas
as just a fun event.
And as for KFC for Christmas in Japan
back in 1970s, Japan KFC
launched a hugely successful
advertising campaign called
(speaks in Japanese),
that's "Kentucky for Christmas."
And with that strong marketing campaign
it became so popular to have
KFC for Christmas in Japan.
And now about 3.6 million
Japanese families eat KFC
for Christmas.
And talking about my
personal experiences, yes,
when I was young, I would
eat KFC for Christmas
with my family but when you start dating,
Christmas makes a transformation
from a family event to couples event
and I'm looking for the one
who can enjoy KFC for Christmas with me.
In the UK a drum is 170 calories.
So in Japan, one drum stick of - Oh.
So in Japan, one drums
stick of Original Chicken
on average has 237 calories.
Chicken's looking a
little limp there George.
In the US one stiff drumstick
of Original Recipe is 130 calories,
but according to KFC's US site,
that's for a 53 gram piece.
Now, adjusting for the 87 gram
piece, like that of Japan,
the calories go up to 210.
Does that make sense?
Great.
Now, take this bad boy
and make him extra crispy,
and you got 270 calories.
It's too many calories.
Mm, not enough calories if you ask me.
But finger licking good.
I think KFC got to George, he
keeps dropping that slogan.
Are they paying George?
I think George is getting some
money on the side from KFC.
Oh my God, if George turns
out to be Colonel Sanders,
I will lose my mind.
We should also point out
that the KFC India website
is a major need of an update.
There is an FAQ page where
people have asked things
like, "How many calories
does this chicken have?"
Or, "Sometimes, I see red
deposits in my chicken.
What is it?"
And for almost all of these questions
the answers are just filler text.
So if you ask me what
those red deposits are,
I genuinely don't know.
Unfortunately, KFC in the UK
doesn't disclose its ingredients.
In the US our Original Recipe
Chicken ingredients are:
first with the fresh chicken,
it is marinated with salt,
sodium phosphate, and
monosodium glutamate.
Onto the breading, it's
breaded with salt, wheat flour,
tricalcium phosphate,
maltodextrin, triglycerides,
natural flavor, Colonel's Secret
Original Recipe seasoning.
So KFC in Japan doesn't
disclose their ingredients.
So we emailed their customer support
and this is what they told us.
Unfortunately, KFC does not share
a full list of ingredients
with the public.
So what do we know about KFC?
Well, the KFC India website
has a couple of clues.
We know that all of our
chicken is farmed here
and not imported.
And all of it is 100 percent
whole muscle chicken.
That means it's made from
whole pieces of chicken
and not cut together mince chicken
like you find in chicken nuggets.
In fact, the website says they
have an Open Kitchen Policy.
And what that means is
anybody can walk into a KFC
and apparently ask for a kitchen tour
and you can go into the kitchen,
look at everything and ask
as many questions as you want.
Indian chicken farmers
were previously criticized
for overusing antibiotics.
As recently as 2018,
the Bureau of Investigative
Journalism found out
that a lot of Indian farmers
were feeding colistin
to their chickens as a growth promoter
without any medical supervision.
Colistin is known as the antibiotic
of the last resort.
Holy sh--!
Oh my God, that's so frightening
and is only given to humans
when other antibiotics have failed.
So if we give our chickens colistin
then the humans who consume it
might become resistant to it.
In fact, they can develop a
antibiotic resistant superbug
and that's not good.
Yuelei, this sounds like
the plot to a horror movie.
What is he talking about?
That is terrifying.
I'm going to assume we don't do that here,
and if we do, oh God!
But when the report came out
talking about the ill effects
of colistin, India ended
up banning it completely,
so we're safe from colistin at last.
I kind of look like
Colonel Sanders, right?
Look, this guy
I'm a younger Colonel Sanders.
KFC is doing any sort
of the adventures of Young
Colonel Sanders ad campaign.
Is this a face that could sell chicken?